ce train est vraiment mon jouet préféré
je pourrais jouer des jours et des jours
avec sans m'en lasser regardez comme les
wagons sont jolies
d'ailleurs je joue avec depuis des jours
elles mêmes des semaines
et évidemment la peinture commence un
peu à ces cahiers il fait un petit peu
trop de bruit en roulant
enfin c'est quand même curieux comme
personne ne pense jamais à m'offrir des
jouets neufs personne même pas ma tante
adélaïde d'ailleurs
léonard léonard du montant alloué
casimir jeu contenant
est ce que tu ne t'ennuies pas
faisait la sieste ah bon toujours les
mêmes livres et toujours les mêmes
jouets toujours les mêmes bombes qui ont
toujours la même goût
personne ne pense à nous
il n'a plus qu'une chose à faire ah bon
et laquelle léonard
ainsi s casimir bah
ouais alors bonne sieste c est quasiment
il y en a
ils ont quand même de deux bouts jouait
les enfants dans le jardin
et des bonbons tout nouveau ouais
surtout ce que julie a reçu hier qui
sont encore dans son kiosque
bonne sieste oyonnax princesse casimir
kazemi oui j'ai fait une idée aura une
bonne idée au moins est ce que tu as une
grande combe très long
j'ai l'accord d'un avec laquelle je
m'entraîne pour faire du lasso web
emportements voilà la voie
menant au bord de la marne et athus
décison des ciseaux à des ciseaux oui à
temps
mais voilà
le vrai que nous avons beaucoup de mon
ex et écoute un salon prend mais s'ils
sont d'accord et pour moi
[Applaudissements]
dans mon pays les hirondelles rendre
tous les jours les brouteurs
mes amis y est gwen au piano tout sujet
prenez aussi des cadenas rodado totaux
soit noir du 30 au volant qui me tombe
renault ici je suis un grand bravo et un
excellent contre eux chardy
or je suis vraiment spécial
comme un montreur os aussi et rêverie et
prestidigitateur et jordon
chaque régate agne et en escargot de la
trompette
doris bleus sur les premiers et
citrouilles sur les oiseaux tic dans le
pays où pourrait voir un éléphant qui
tous les soirs rachou
sur les trottoirs croyez moi ou pas les
six mois que je suis en grand
[Musique]
ces rencontres
richard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
je suis encore là
et rossi et recours
restellini l'egypte
j'ai vu sont couvertes de fleurs et les
enfants jamais de klose il ya du soleil
mais mendy terre on n'a jamais pris de
kyuss mais son sens ankara m rigueur
coutumière l'amitié sera et r c'est la
dernière monde nous elle je suis un
grand coeur et on excelle en contres
cher dit
je suis au travail
prise en compte
si les réponses
esprit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bon tiers
[Musique]
chagny
il est
il reste il dit je
crois
en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car si
nous apprenons
[Musique]
le jury
il faut que mon stand soit prêt pour la
fin de dimanche alors je le dis quand tu
vois un vin que des vers de terre qui
joue on serre sont des mouches à son
couteau et est plein de petites marches
partout ça va être magnifique
[Musique]
dis moi tu vu mais nous mais beaucoup
j'ai acheté des nouveaux bonbons ans
j'en suis ravi pour toi puis des
nouveaux joueurs découpez les voitures
j'espère que les enfants vont être
contents ouais il n'y a pas que les
enfants
commençaient tout ce que ça veut dire il
n'y a pas que l'on
est bien je suppose que les parents
aussi
je crains que j'avais gagné il étagères
il faut que je prenne mes toiles
deux bombes attend plus bas à la raison
dix mois lehman a oui tu peux me
regarder mon cas
à fin juin
je sais bien julie je ne vois pas très
bien oui mais sa feria j'en ai pour très
peu par une dépêche à bon d'accord
pour une fois léonard a même une idée
formidable
voyons ce nouveau jouet
magnifique bateau
pourquoi les envies de ce qu'il ya au
bout d autres cordes
à ça alors à un bocal de bongo comme je
n'en n'ai encore jamais vu
étant donné que je sois encore plus
curieux que gourmands je préfère
regarder ce qu'il ya proue des autres
avant de les goûter
des aînés
casimir tu es là je peux entrer mais oui
françois en fait comme chez points mais
casimir je venais qu'emprunter ton livre
sur les poissons et les coquillages je
te dérange même en sortant du rouge
était en train de préparer un nouveau
jeu mais c'est un secret je voulais pas
tant parler alors je t'expliquerai dans
quelques jours un génie c'est formidable
ça casimir les méduses veut rien dire
j'aperçois la bad et les jouets que
j'avais encore jamais vus et ils sont
attachés avec deux longues cordes
pincées va bien c'est ça c'est un peu
comme le jeu de la pêche je
t'expliquerai tout ça à quand ce sera
terminé un bientôt aller tiens voilà ton
livre en voir si casimir vos poubelles
j'attendrai puisque les 100 m dirai
merci pour le livre au revoir françois
revoir
les projets d'ici mais enfin léonard il
est impossible que toutes ces choses se
soit envolé sous sa surveillance
françois tu te rends compte
tous les objets en kiosques ont disparu
comme ça tout seul moi je deviens folle
se calme il s'agit d'un tour de
prestidigitation très simple tu vas voir
les honore tu n'as rien vu ta place j'ai
compris on tue c'est franchement j'ai eu
une très mauvaise vue
bien eu léonard qui va prendre la place
de julie dans son kiosque
exactement ce que je te dis sinon je
raconte tout à julie j'ai compris autres
manèges à toi et à casimir qui va dire à
casimir de venir ici immédiatement sinon
je raconte tout aux enfants on est
franchement je ferai quand tu voudras
mais ne dit rien à personne boudeur l'on
trompe casimir et moi alors léonard va
prendre la place de julie dans le
kiosque et toi julie tu vas prendre la
place de léonard derrière son stand tu
es d'accord
je ne comprends rien tous ses mystères
bochy grouchy rouchy j'ai perdu mon
petit lapin jaune en peluche c'est bien
triste ben alors je suis venue te
demander où ils se trouvent enfin
comment veux tu que je le sache mais tu
es bien magicien ouais mais pas
détective tu as une baguette magique et
une boule de cristal qui te servent
souvent à deviner les choses et avoir
dans l'avenir alors alors quoi alors
peut-être qu'en regardant dans ta boule
de cristal magique tu verras où se
trouve mon petit lapin jaune en peluche
non non non je ne peux vraiment rien
pour toi ô mais alors tu es enfant
magicien mais ta poule n'est même pas
une vraie boule en cristal c'est une
vieille boule en verre
mon pauvre thomas ce n'est pas parce que
j'ai une boule de cristal que je peux
empêcher ton la plage on ne se perdre de
même que ce n'est pas parce que tu as un
parapluie que tu empêches la pluie
tombait ce n'est pas non plus parce que
il y à des policiers que les voleurs
n'existe pas tu es d'accord avec moi ben
oui tu as raison mais je pensais que tu
pourrais quand même aider à retrouver
mon petit lapin voilà touba oui il faut
que tu cesses de compter sur les autres
pour tous tu as l'âge de prendre ses
responsabilités tu te rends tu as perdu
ton la panne y est bien cherche le toi
même abou grouchy tu sais que tu es un
vrai ami tu vous donne toujours de très
très bons conseils je te remercie ah oui
je te remercie il n'y a vraiment pas de
quoi ça fera cinq francs 1 et c'est cher
c'est le produit remarque c'est vrai
c'est quand même un très bon conseil tu
sais que tu devrais en faire ton métier
mais c'est une excellente de là ben oui
je pense alors au jeu je te remercie
touba enfin il n'y a pas de quoi ça fera
6 francs
[Rires]
non
regarde bien joli
tu vas voir
et voilà
voilà
mais qu'est ce qui me prend j'attends
mais françois léonard disparaît comme
mes jouets mais bon comment tu as fait
c'est un tour que m'a appris casimir
vieux secrets de la famille des casimir
us mais il n'a pas encore tout dit
attente ils reviennent et attends toi à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus fort
comme ça
parle à un jouet qui
[Musique]
parvenaient pas à jouer
cette fois
c'est moi la nar
françois a tout découvert et aimé
attaché au bout de la corde françois
c'est tout
ne dit rien si tu vas tout de suite le
rejoindront la jv mais quelle
catastrophe un long mur toujours de
mauvaises idées leona je découpe pour te
faire plaisir
et voilà où nous en sambre
quant à moi je sais ce qui m'a pas cette
affaire
a besoin de moi françois nous est
quasiment car toi seul peut réussir la
prestidigitation secrète des kazemi
russe ren mais je ne sais pas si je
pourrai alors allo allo kazimiyah
casimir elle se fait pas prier je lis tu
regardes ont peut-être mais je ne me
souviens pas très bien il faut que tu
veux mettre sur la voie en sur la voie
ratha by rata bing tapis
du prend les cordes
qui sortent du kiosque et du tir d'un
coup sec à les dotant d'un coup c'est
quand on est d'accord at abidal accord
françois bon
tapis
roulant bravo kadhimiya mais tu es
formidable tu sais pas ça que j'ai
retrouvé tous mes jouets parce que entre
nous ni léonard ne reçoit aucun
cas jimmy
[Musique]